وينضم الينا من مساجسس الدكتور فريد حافظ
العضو في مبادره الجسر بجامعه جورج تاون
بروفيسور حافظ لو بايجاز فقط وضعنا في
صوره حيثيات هذا الحكم باغلاق بهذا الملف
ايضا ان اعبر عن شكري
الجزيره العربيه والجزيره الانجليزيه
حول عمليه الاقصر كما سميت بالنسبه لي
شخصيا هذا يوم جميل لان
ابل تكون التحقيقات
تم ابطال ما توصلت اليه وايضا المحكمه
النقض اثبتات بان كل الادعاءات كانت زائفه
ولا توجد ايه اسباب وجيهه تدعو الاستمرار
في ايه التحقيقات لها علاقه بتهمه الارهاب
بان يشكل عدو للدوله جزء من منظمه اجراميه
او منظمه تمويل الارهاب وما الى ذلك كما
زعم من قبل الدعاء العام قبل نحوي عامين
او اكثر انا واحد من بين 30 شخصا واجهه
هذه التحقيقات وقد تم ايقافها الان واسقاط
التهم
وهناك ايضا اكثر من 70 شخصا ما زالوا
متاثرين تتوقعوا ان يتم ايقاف التحقي
بشانهم ايضا قريبا
على البراءه ولكن نريد ان توضح للمشاهدين
ونذكرهم اكثر
بالوثائق السريه التي كشف عنها تحقيق ما
خفي اعظم والتي كانت ادله استخدمت في
المحكمه لسقطتها
نعم تماما
القضيه
لم يتم
الكشف عنها ايضا
الحكومه التي كانت تدعمه هذه المزاعم
وايضا عمليات الاتحاد التي تمت لاماكن في
الخامسه فجرا اخافه الكثير من الاطفال
والمئات من الناس تعرضوا لمثل هذا عمليات
الذهب
بسبب بمزاعم تتعلق بالارهاب حقيقه ما حصل
ان الحكومه لم تكن راغبه حقا باجراء تحقيق
كامل
لتعمليات الذهب التي تمت والتحقيقات التي
ما تزال مستمره همم اشخاص
اخرين لكن اذا ما عدنا الى حيثيات القضيه
نرى ان هناك نقطتان مهمتان في التسلسل
الزمني اولا يبدو ان التحقيق بدا ضد اشخاص
كانوا
يحتجون ضد النظام الديكتاتوري في مصر لهذا
السبب هناك اسباب تدعوا الى الاعتقاد بان
الاجهزه الامن السريه همم لم تتصرف من
حياله نفسها كانت ربما
تتصرف بناء على دفع من اجهزه امنيه اخرى
هذا
الجانب الاخر وهو التحقيق الذي شملني الذي
ادى كانت بسبب القياده النمساويه والتي
اتخذت خطوات ضد الجاريه المسلم انا شخصيا
كنت همم من ذلك
وحكوما المحافظه تحت قياده السباس كتله
الذي التي كانت تقف ضد مساله الحجاب
كيف كيف ساهما تحقيق الجزيره ما خفيه اعظم
في
الوصول هذه النتيجه وهي اغلاق هذا الملف
توثيق الذي قام
من خلال برنامج
كثير من الصحفيين الذي كانوا ينتقدون هذا
القضيه لكن لم يكن احد راغبا في التعمق
اكثر في القضيه لعدم وجود دعم من سياسه
صحيح اننا راينا النظام
العظميا مستقلا يحاول ان يبقي على نفسه
مستقله تاثيرات السياسيه لكن في الحقيقه
لم يكن هناك احد
يحاول التحقيق بتعلق بالعلاقات الخارجيه
لهذا السبب البرنامج الذي عرضته الجزيره
ساعد على اضاحي هذه الامور وعلى مستوى
عالميا شامل
البروفيسور ان هناك متهمين اخرين لم تحسم
همم ملفاتهم في هذه القضيه هلا شرحت لنا
ما الذي جرى معهم ولماذا لم تحسم حتى الان
معركه قانونيه قضائيه ما تزال مستمره وانت
تحتاج الى الادوات الصحيح انا فقط يمكن ان
اقول لكم ما قال لي محاميه عندما التقيته
في
المره الثانيه قال لهذه عقوبه لك بسبب
انتقاداتك وهي محاوره لتخويفك
وتدبرك على التزامي الصمت وان لا تنتقد
التمييز ضد المسلمين الذي تقوم به الجهات
سياسيه طبعا الادعاء امامه ثلاثه سنوات
اما
له قدما للقضيه او اسقاط التهم انا
بالنسبه لي بعد عامين تقريبا في النهايه
بعد مرور عام اخر كل التهم ستسق واضح ان
الذين كانت لديهم القدره على الدفاع عن
نفسه وعندهم من يمثلهم قانونا كان وضعهم
افضل من غيرهم الذين لم يحوزوا هذه
الوسائل اعتقد انه بعد عام من الان لن
تكون هناك اي تهم لانه بعد عامين بعيده
عامين من عمليات الذهب لم تكن هناك حقيقه
اليوم ايضا همم محكمه النقض التي طعنت في
هذه
التهام واوضحت انها تهم زائفه غير لا
تستند الى الادله طبعا هذا كان مع
الثلاثين شخصا الذين تاثروا وانا على ثقه
من القضيه ستتكرر مع السبعين شخصا الاخرين
ايضا
بنسبه لك بروفيسور حافظ باغلاق هذه الملف
هل انتهت هذه القضيه ام انك سوف تشرع في
اجراءات من قبيل مثلا طلب تعويضات
نعم نحن سوف
نستمر في قتالنا وكفاحنا بالتاكيد لتحقيق
العداله قدر المستطاع في هذه القضيه انا
من جهه اشعر بتواضع كبير
وشكر وامتنان
لتلقي هذا القرار من محكمه النقض والتي
تحدثت
كل القضايا للثلاثين شخصا لكن في عين
الوقت يجب ان لا ننسى ان وزير الداخليه
الذي كان مسؤولا عن هذا هو الان مستشار
دوله
النمسا وانا لا ارى اي رغبه من جانب
الحكومه الافغانيه بمحاوله التصالح مع هذا
الوضع
وفي قضيه لم تستند ابدا الى اي مشروعيه
واعتقد ان
منظمات المجتمع المدني والمجتمع بشكل عام
يحتاجون الى معرفه ما حدث مع هذا السلوك
غير المقدس وهذه الحرب الصليبيه التي
تعرضت لها الرجال المسلمه وكانت تجلياتها
هذه القضيه التي نتحدث عنها
الدكتور فريد حافظ العضو في مبادره الجسر
بجامعه جورج تاون شكرا